[APPLAUSE]
AVERY SUNSHINE: So I wanted
to do a couple of songs
from the new record.
I was going to let
you all hear them,
so I'm going to
do one real quick.
AUDIENCE: I thought you
were going to do two.
AVERY SUNSHINE:
What did you say?
Huh?
But no, if I do
two of those, then
I can't do the other
songs that they--
you know what I'm saying?
Very well?
You hear Ike Turner?
Did you hear him?
[LAUGHTER]
AVERY SUNSHINE: So I've got
to set this up really quickly.
So I have to say, something
that we never really talk about,
we never talk about
equal love and all that.
I was blessed to be born
into a family where my eldest
brother is a same
gender loving person.
Y'all know what I'm
talking about, right?
Absolutely.
And I felt like I wanted
to address that because he
is the godfather of my
children, and I wanted people
to know that one of the best
examples that I had seen
for love had been with my
brother and his partner
of some 20 years.
So I figured out
the way I could say
this was something like this.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SEE YOU WHEN I GET THERE"]
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Those folk that talk.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SEE YOU WHEN I GET THERE"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all know
what I'm talking about?
You love who you
want to love, believe
what you want to believe,
have the career that you
want to have.
Anybody really, really know
what I'm talking about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AVERY SUNSHINE: I
still feel like we're
going to make it
to the other side.
All right.
So I see you when I get there.
I might choose not to
wear shoes on stage,
but I'm going to be on the
other side with no shoes on.
I hope you really, really
get it, and I have to say--
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SEE YOU WHEN I GET THERE"]
AVERY SUNSHINE:
[INAUDIBLE], here we go.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SEE YOU WHEN I GET THERE"]
[APPLAUSE]
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Thank y'all so much.
And that means so much to me.
I hope y'all like that song.
My brother hasn't heard it yet.
I can't wait for him to hear it.